do you guys ever fight and get mad at
each other you guys are working together
so often everything You' said that you
do together do you guys yeah no it it is
I mean we've had what
three we only had three like actual like
fights physical fight physical fights
who won no there's the thing they were
the dumbest I've never I've never hit
him I would never hit him Jonathan had
no problem hitting me so uh when when we
had our fights when we were like
teenagers and then W when we were
probably early 20s or around 20 that's
not true you threw me on a moving car
what that that was in high school in
high school yeah so here are our three
fights one was when we were really
little we were in a hotel room and we
were kind of picking on Drew and
whatever and he was you know I don't
know you were annoying me somehow doing
whatever and and so then I ended up just
like we were like ah and then I boxed
his ears and he started bleeding from
his ear and I was like I thought I was
in so much trouble so I was like H and I
locked myself in the motel bathroom wait
you thought you were the scary thing was
you thought you were in trouble not that
he went down exactly oh he's bleeding
from the ears Bo I'm in trouble I
scratched his ear I turned out what it
was but everything is actually Jonathan
teaming up or ganging on me so the next
one was in high school him and our our
bestie they had saved up they were just
kept harassing me they saved up all
these old sandwiches for weeks and weeks
and weeks they're all rotten and moldy
and they shoved them in my locker they
knew my code and uh anyway they did that
and he pulled on my backstrap and that
was like the straw on the camel's back
he had pulled my backpack and the strap
ripped and so I was like God and they
tried to run away and he went but it was
my buddy that did it not me
grabed me are you saying that because
you're afraid you're going to get in
trouble so he Pedro is faster than
Jonathan he took off and Pedro yeah
Pedro well his name is pedum but we call
him Pedro but Pedro in Vancouver that's
unusual yeah right is it there's a large
well that's well he's Iran he's Aran I'm
just thinking Pedro because you know we
have uh I've never seen never mind
moving on okay yeah I know stop with the
face stop with the face so Jonathan was
slower than Pedro and he ran ran out the
front where all the the cars were
pulling up to pick up students and then
he's like don't you dare come after me
and I grabbed my thr in front of a car
that was pulling up and the woman the
mom who was in the car had a heart
attack cuz she was like it student just
bounces off her windshield and that was
that the third and final fight that
we've had but the thing is that did you
explain to the woman like she got out
she stopped I was fine yeah she's only
going like two sorry my brother's mad
Pedro puts sandwiches in his clocker
exctly like why don't you explain it Mak
sense that Pedro so much sense oh
Pedro UHD vote Pedro all right so next
uh was when we were in college uh Drew
was in he was in our side alley and he
was being really annoying you see
there's a Common Thread here wait wait
wait he's in your side alley he's in the
side alley sitting in the car in his car
sounds super annoying yeah and he's he's
just being like he's like chirping at me
telling me to do something I'm like and
so finally I I'm so fed up he's in a
side alley chirping I'm just reiterating
for the people at home he grab I reach
in I grab his keys out of the ignition
and then I say to him like all right
well good luck finding these and I just
throw his keys down the alley I walk he
flies like a banshee out of the car and
I'm like don't you do it I'm done I like
clench my fist I clench my teeth and I
broke my own tooth no no sorry yeah yeah
wow you showed
him your own tooth but it was you know
what I'm going to do to you and yeah
busted my own damn tooth so what what
we've learned is Jonathan bullying and
being selfish and then uh but that's
when you're kids nothing when you're
older and then you still have to work
together and film no I think our we call
it our no BS policy the way we work
together and the way we you know we get
on each other's nerves from time to time
everybody who spends time together will
but we get we get over it if there's
something we get it yeah see exactly you
get it out you deal with it you move
on
I